foreign
Cody is in New York to start off this
day this hour hey Cody how are you
hi Dave it's uh great to be on the phone
with you you too finally meet you I've
been watching you for a little while now
well thank you how can we help
um so I had a question
um about I recently put myself
um back a couple baby steps uh by going
and getting myself a truck loan but now
uh A girlfriend of mine of course you
know not married so you know I know
roughly what where I'm already at
thinking you know especially watching
you
um she wants me to finance a car for her
um I was thinking if she comes up with a
large down payment you know I'm in
pretty decent uh Financial shape myself
you know
no I know that is but that's true
so I was um thinking if I could go
through um
if I should Finance the vehicle for her
or not because
um it's a really big deal to her
obviously she has a vehicle now so in my
eyes she doesn't need one I went and got
it inspected for her so I know it's good
for at least another year
um
I'll get your take on it
Cody if you were to guess what we would
say what would your guess be
of course not I mean
I know oh and here's what sucks a month
toward us so you get it paid off I know
so here's the deal is like it is number
one just taking on debt in general is a
risk and then number two when you put
your your name on someone else's debt
that's a massive risk and we have had
even more risks yeah just so many calls
okay so do you want us to help give you
a good argument to give to your
girlfriend is this part of why you
called yeah yeah that would be great you
know you know I've went over the points
of you know interest rates are higher
right now I have my own you know I've
had the conversation with her you know
like can can you wait until I get my
truck paid off I'm expecting to get my
truck paid off I I financed um 30 33
um 33 400 for it
um I've made literally two payments on
it what do you make
I make about a 120 a year what does she
make
she's making about 800 a week
you can bring home okay and how long you
all been dating
yeah uh like four months
how old are you two
uh I am sir I just turned 30 and she
just turned 19. okay
uh you just described a sugar daddy
yeah yeah you're not kidding
[Laughter]
um yeah she doesn't make any money she's
19 years old
and she wants you to go buy her a truck
um no a car probably or a car Rachel
you're going to crawl out in front of
the desk now
um the uh yeah yeah so you make a lot of
money she didn't make any so uh
number one I don't know that there's an
explanation for her that's going to
satisfy her
okay yeah because uh she's not gonna be
loving a no of any kind no matter how
logical or sweet or well crafted okay uh
so let's just be prepared for the fact
that she ain't gonna like this okay
number two uh if you were my son who is
um just a tiny bit older than you
um I would knock a noggin on your head
if you did this because a lot of reasons
number one what Rachel said you're gonna
get yourself in a mess number two of
course we teach you not to borrow money
of course we're not going to teach you
to borrow money for for yourself even
after you finally get your truck paid
off because it was a mistake to go in
debt for the truck in the first place
we're gonna stop doing that so that you
can become wealthy making 120 000 a year
okay so we're gonna take that off the
table we're just gonna take that there's
no explanation for it Cody we're taking
debt off the table you called us you
knew what we were going to say so but
here's the biggest problem all right
um relationally this feels like it's
going to be a strain if you don't do it
and I will tell you from having coached
um
folks for 30 years that if you do this
you're going to put a bigger strain on
the relationship because you're changing
the tone the flavor of the relationship
from two independent adults seeking a
high quality connection to now one is
dependent upon the other
all right and it changes the it changes
dinner
on me it yeah yeah yeah because you just
and now you're somewhat dependent upon
her because if she doesn't pay the
payment making 800 a week shock
um then you're going to end up having to
pay the payments shock okay and uh then
there's going to be another strain on
the relationship and so you're going to
do damage
to whatever the quality of this
relationship is it's going to get worse
if you do this yeah so that's the
biggest reason not to do it the second
biggest reason not to do it is there is
nothing no scenario that turns out
positive out of this all the scenarios
are negative and I think too Cody I
would I would be curious on the
relational side how she takes the no
probably reveals a lot about her right
and and the kind of person you want to
be in relationship with and so what
she's really doing here yeah you know
and it but if she's willing to learn and
she's like okay so why won't you co-sign
you're like well because of this and
this and this and I want to get out of
debt I want to do you know what I mean
and you may teach her something new
which is great you know I'm not saying
she's like a bad person but y'all's
value systems might be might be very
very different and then the other thing
that would it would happen too if you
co-sign and she loses a job or she
suddenly decides oh I'm gonna go on a
fun girls trip and spend money and oh
sure I just can't make my car payment
this month and you're thinking you just
went on a girls trip and you're not
going to pay your payment and now I'm
stuck with like you're going to start
analyzing everything that she buys and
purchases and so like it just yeah the
whole thing it's it's just so it's it's
very messy so let's be real clear it
won't be co-signing because there's no
Bank in the world going to say her up or
anything
no that's probably that's probably yeah
she's living below the poverty level so
you're gonna own a car
with a car payment and then you're gonna
have to go pick up your car
from your ex-girlfriend when you break
up
this is going to be and then you're
going to feel terrible if you broke up
with her one day and then you have to go
be like I need my car back she's like I
don't have a car I'm gonna get to work
and now you're dependent you're still I
mean it's just yeah yeah no good plan
but Cody I appreciate you calling yeah
thanks for for asking yeah I and uh I I
sympathize with where you are and you're
a nice guy trying to think about this
yes yes you did call the people who tell
people not to borrow money so that they
can become wealthy and outrageously
generous and has to borrow money period
bad idea number two doing that with
people or four people that you're not
married to bad idea number three when
the person you're doing it for is
completely broken makes no money so a
bad idea so let's just keep adding on to
this this is the Ramsay show